Situado en los Alpes, a orillas del Rin,
entre Suiza y Austria se encuentra el
sexto país más pequeño y al mismo
tiempo uno de los tres más ricos de
todo el mundo. En una era de súper
estados, luchas de poder entre grandes
potencias y una creciente
centralización cuesta tomar en serio a
un país de sólo 160 kilómetros
cuadrados y 36 mil habitantes. Pero, como
veremos, el Principado de Liechtenstein
cuenta con algunas de las estructuras
políticas y económicas más
sobresalientes que podemos encontrar y
que le han permitido alcanzar un PIB per
cápita de aproximadamente 150.000
dólares, unas cinco veces el de España.
Su sistema político es totalmente
distinto a cualquier cosa que hayáis
conocido antes y aunque muchas de
sus características sean imposibles de
exportar a cualquier otro país
hay que reconocer que les funciona. Hoy
te vamos a contar todos sus detalles.
Sí, sé que muchos pensaréis,
¿Liechtenstein? Eso es un paraíso fiscal y eso
lo explica todo.
Sin embargo más allá del controvertido
debate acerca de si lo es o no lo es lo
cierto es que esta interpretación de
los hechos es muy limitada y nos
oculta muchísimos elementos
institucionales, muchísimas
características particulares que han
logrado por ejemplo que este pequeño
principado consolide una economía muy
industrializada y con altas tasas de
innovación. Es verdad, casi un tercio de
la economía depende del sector
financiero pero el 40% de la mano de
obra trabaja en un sector industrial de
muy alto valor añadido que cada año
genera un saldo de la balanza comercial,
esto es de la diferencia en
exportaciones de bienes importaciones de
bienes, sin tener en cuenta los servicios
de más de mil millones de euros, una
cifra impresionante para un Estado de
poco más de 35 mil habitantes. Bueno, es
que sería una cifra extraordinaria
incluso para un país 100 veces más
grande. Buen ejemplo todo esto es por
ejemplo Vivadent, uno de los mayores
proveedores de equipamiento para
dentistas de todo el mundo que desde Liechtenstein
exporta a más de 120 países.
Todo Liechtenstein nos resulta diferente
empezando por su monarquía que a
diferencia de la mayoría de las
monarquías del resto del continente
europeo mantiene muchísimas facultades
y tiene un rol esencial en el gobierno
diario del principado.
De hecho, prácticamente podemos decir
que en Liechtenstein se conservan muchos
elementos del Antiguo Régimen.
La monarquía, así, mantiene por ejemplo el
derecho a nombrar jueces la capacidad de
fijar vetos legislativos o incluso de
disolver el parlamento.
Sin lugar a dudas, la monarquía de Liechtenstein la más poderosa de toda Europa y, por
cierto, también la más rica. La
fortuna de la familia real se calcula en
no menos de 5.000 millones de dólares,
de hecho no cobran nada del principado y
en entre sus activos se encuentran bancos y
muchísimas empresas. Pero claro, este
sistema no implica que en Liechtenstein no
no existan derechos civiles todo lo
contrario,  Liechtenstein es una de las
democracias directa son más avanzadas,
más desarrollada de todo el mundo. Las
iniciativas populares son comunes y
apenas se requieren mil firmas o el
apoyo de tres municipios para presentar
cualquier proyecto de ley,
además los ciudadanos tienen la
capacidad de movilizarse y votar para
establecer o suprimir cualquier ley,
cualquier reglamento o incluso modificar
la constitución.
De esta forma los ciudadanos de Liechtenstein,
por ejemplo, podrían suprimir la
monarquía mediante un procedimiento
perfectamente reglado y ya establecido.
Además todas las leyes que apruebe el
parlamento deben de contar con el
plácet, esto es con el refrendo de la
ciudadanía de Liechtenstein, mediante
referendos facultativos. Incluso los ciudadanos de Liechtenstein pueden determinar mediante su voto
municipios qué personas reciben o no la
ciudadanía de este país. Por supuesto,
en lo referente a derechos civiles del
reconocimiento que de éstos hace la
legislación de este país lo convierte
en uno de los países más libres de
todo el mundo según todos los
organismos internacionales.
Aquí vemos la controversia entre una
monarquía con reminiscencias del
Antiguo Régimen y una de las
democracias más avanzadas del mundo.
Todo ello en un diminuto territorio
situado en el corazón de Europa. Por
cierto, el actual Jefe del Estado es el
príncipe Hans-Adam II, un tipo
también muy peculiar porque a pesar de
su papel como monarca es un libertario
de bandera. Un libertario que propugna
que tenemos que ver al Estado como un
proveedor de servicios cuyos clientes
son los ciudadanos que en todo momento
tienen que tener la capacidad de buscar
una alternativa en el mercado privado o
incluso en otro Estado si no están
satisfechos con lo servicios recibidos.
Creo que es un antiguo concepto en
algunas monarquías que eres tú quien
sirva a la gente, por ejemplo el Príncipe de Inglaterra,
el Príncipe Carlos, tiene en su escudo de armas "Ich Dien", la antigua expresión alemana  yo
sirvo, y creo que es a lo que tenemos
que ver en el futuro, que la gente no sirva
al Estado sino que el Estado sirva a la
gente, ¿cómo puedes hacerlo lo mejor
posible? ¿qué tarea puedes hacer mejor que nadie?
Así precisamente para estimular esta
especie de competencia y limitar el
comportamiento arbitrario de los poderes
públicos el príncipe favoreció que en
2003 se aprobase una enmienda
constitucional que otorga el derecho de
secesión a todos y cada uno de los once
municipios que conforman Liechtenstein.
Así, si los habitantes de uno de los
municipios de Liechtenstein no están
contentos con el encaje que tienen en el
principado o no están satisfechos con
los servicios recibidos pueden votar y
declararse Estado soberano o incluso
aderirse a un tercer país, algo
absolutamente inédito en todo el mundo.
"Cualquier municipio tienen el derecho de
dejar el país, pueden decir ok
queremos ser independientes o queremos
entrar en Suiza, en Austria o donde sea".
En lo referente a la economía y como
buen libertario, ¿qué es lo que define el
príncipe Hans-Adam II?
Bueno, pues el príncipe defiende unos
impuestos reducidos y sencillo de
aplicar y comprender, la privatización
en la media lo posible de las
actividades y los servicios que el
Estado ofrece, la liberalización
de los sectores económicos y el
tráfico comercial,
la atracción de inversiones y la
eliminación de subsidios.
Una política que a tenor de los datos
ha tenido los últimos decenios un
éxito impresionante en el Principado de
Liechtenstein. Por cierto, en el año 2009 el
príncipe presentó una obra titulada "El
Estado en el Tercer Milenio", en la que
recoge su visión sobre el papel que han
de jugar los Estados para generar
bienestar para sus ciudadanos y que es
muy recomendable para todos aquellos que
creen más en la iniciativa de las
personas que en las decisiones de los
burócratas.
Son muchos los que afirman que esta
visión está influenciada por las
particulares características de los
Estados pequeños que a la postre
suponen un freno a la intervención
gubernamental pero, ¿cuáles son esas
características? Bien, en primer lugar,
lo normal en un estado pequeño es que
su territorio se encuentre próximo al
de un Estado vecino de tal forma que sus
ciudadanos conocen lo que ocurre fuera
de sus fronteras y que en un momento
determinado si el gobierno les maltrata
puedan tomar la decisión de cruzar la
frontera y trasladarse a los Estados
colindantes. Es lo que podríamos
denominar con una emigración
competitivas o, incluso, una emigración
disuasoria. En segundo lugar, en los
Estados pequeños no pueden hacer de las
políticas proteccionistas políticas
relevantes porque sus mercados internos
no son lo suficientemente grandes como
para abastecer sus necesidades, de tal
forma que para cumplir con las demandas
de sus ciudadanos tienen que confiar en
el tráfico comercial.
Y, en tercer lugar, en los Estados
pequeños los ciudadanos suelen ser menos
propensos a aceptar la redistribución
de la riqueza, entre otras cosas porque
ésta les impacta de una forma mucho
más directa y además los gobiernos
tienen una debilidad mayor respecto a la
mala situación financiera lo que limita
mucho su ambición por gastar y gastar.
Por todo ello Liechtenstein es uno de los pocos
países de todo el mundo que carece de
deuda pública, su apertura comercial es
una de las más altas de todo el planeta.
En Liechtenstein no hay paro, no hay
corrupción y los impuestos son
reducidos. Precisamente en lo respectivo
impuestos me gustaría destacar su
impuesto sobre beneficios es un tipo
único del 12,5 por ciento, el IVA es de
apenas el 8% y el impuesto sobre
salarios y rentas profesionales oscila
entre el 3 y el 24 por ciento. Es decir
unos impuestos moderados que no tienen
nada que ver con los que tenemos en
España o con los que son norma
habitual en Europa.
Por cierto, para incentivar la
investigación el desarrollo y la
innovación, el gobierno de Liechtenstein
tiene una exención del 80 por ciento
sobre todos los beneficios procedentes
de la propiedad intelectual, es decir, sobre
licencias, patentes, diseños...
El resultado es que Liechtenstein gasta el
7% de su Producto Interior Bruto en
investigación y desarrollo. Para
hacernos una idea España sólo gasta el
1,2 por ciento, cinco veces menos.
Democracia directa, derecho a
autodeterminación, impuestos bajos,
libertad comercial y mucha prosperidad.
Como veis, Liechtenstein es mucho más que
un paraíso fiscal y desde luego es uno de
los modelos que más bienestar han
conseguido generar a sus ciudadanos.
Bueno y qué pensáis vosotros, ¿creéis
que el éxito de Liechtenstein tiene más
que ver con sus políticas que con su
condición de establecimiento financiero?
¿Creéis que podemos aprender algo de este
pequeño país? ¿Consideráis que este tipo
de países pequeños pueden ser
importantes en este nuevo siglo?
Bueno, espero que os haya gustado el
video. ¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!